it is September 8th 2023 and you're
watching the code report yesterday was a
huge day for soy devs Mojo became
generally available a super set of
python that's up to 35 000 times faster
but JavaScript also got way faster
thanks to a new Swiss army knife called
bun and that means it's time for some
new stickers on my MacBook Pro
JavaScript developers have grown tired
of Reinventing new Frameworks so now
we're building an entirely new
JavaScript runtimes in the beginning we
had node.js it then rearranged the
letters to make Dino and now we've got
bun fresh out of the oven which just hit
1.0 this morning and you should take
notice because it can run your
JavaScript code faster than any other
tool known to man but not just that it
also acts as a bundler like webpack or
Veet a test Runner like jest or Karma
and a package manager like npm or yarn
in addition it's almost fully compatible
with existing node.js apis but has its
own set of Highly optimized apis that
actually make it fun to build high
performance server-side applications
with JavaScript before we get into it
though I want to show you another
awesome new tool from our sponsor devgpt
by now you've heard of tools like chat
gbt and co-pilot but devgpt takes AI
code generation to the next level by
integrating directly with your git repo
giving the AI the full context of your
Tech stack and project after writing a
prompt to fix a bug or create a feature
It'll ask follow-up questions to write
highly targeted and useful code once the
code is generated you can then sync
those changes to your local project
instantly then you could prompt it to
generate some unit tests to validate
that code it's like having an automated
engineer by your side who can take care
of your GitHub issues and jira tickets
instantly without complaining you can
try it out for free yourself right now
with the link below but now let's get
back to bun first of all how do they
make this thing so fast one major
difference compared to node and Dino
which uses the V8 engine from chrome bun
uses JavaScript core from Safari which
is known to be optimized for faster
startup times in addition bun is
implemented in the zig programming
language they've put a focus on profile
and performance bottlenecks and
Implement apis in native code the end
result is a hello world with typescript
that's five times faster than es build
keep in mind though benchmarks can
always be cherry-picked and rarely
reflect real world performance it's fun
to go fast but because I only have 12
monthly active users on my website it
doesn't make a huge difference for me
what I care about is the developer
experience can bun make my life easier
well first up it's got awesome
typescript support out of the box you
can immediately start writing typescript
code without any configuration or
headaches and it also supports jsx and
hot reloading which means you don't need
any weird dependencies like node mod and
concurrently to recompile your code when
things change that's cool but one of the
absolute worst things about node has
been the transition from common JS to es
modules what's cool about bun is that
you can just use import and require in
the same file and everything just
magically works and it's compatible with
existing node.js packages which means
you don't have to reinvent the wheel for
every little thing you want to implement
Dino also added npm support as well
recently but what I really like about
bun is its native apis for example to
read and write to the file system we can
access the global bun runtime and make a
reference to a file then lazily read it
or parse its Json that may not seem like
a big deal but in node.js there are
three different ways to do this same
thing read file with callbacks read file
with promises or read file sync you can
actually use all of those in bun but not
only are the native apis faster they're
easier to use in addition it's extremely
easy to set up an HTTP server in bun by
simply calling the serve method you then
use familiar browser Primitives like
Fetch and response to build your API
that'll take you pretty far but there's
also Frameworks that work with bun like
Elysia that claims to be 18 times faster
than express.js and node but it also
works with hono which has been my go-to
framework for building apis recently bun
has tons of other simplifications as
well like it makes websockets nice and
simple out of the box without any extra
dependencies and you can use environment
variables without things like dot EnV
pretty cool but as the name implies bun
is also a bundler the bun build command
will take all your source files and then
combine them into a single output that
can be used in a browser and based on
this Benchmark it's pretty amazing how
much faster things have gotten just
since webpack 5 a couple years ago oh
and another really cool thing is that
bun has a sqlite database built directly
into the runtime it's incredibly
convenient to have a relational database
without the need to install and
configure a bunch of drivers another
thing we need to talk about though is
the button package manager that's up to
25 times faster than npm and it's
actually a standalone tool that can be
used in any node.js project today if you
want to make things go faster right now
replace npx with a command like bunks
Cal say hello world which allows you to
save a few precious milliseconds when
saying hi to your mom which is important
because you never know how much time you
have left to do that this has been the
code report thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one
[Music]